[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy os quiero platicar sobre uno de los
ecosistemas más amenazados en el mundo y
que aún se conservan en la comunidad de
1000 palta
estos son los pastizales y se encuentran
ubicados al sur de la ciudad de mexico
los pastizales aquí en milk palta los
podemos encontrar a partir de los 2 mil
800 hasta los 3.600 metros sobre el
nivel del mar en mil falta podemos
encontrar pastizal abierto donde casi no
existen árboles son llanos y también
podemos encontrar asociaciones pino
pastizal o había es pastizal
el pasto es está formado como por un mco
yo con algunas hojas delgadas y llega a
tener espigas casi todo el año lo puedes
encontrar a una altura de 40 a 50
centímetros pero cuando tiene espigas
puede llegar a tener hasta 2 metros de
altura
antes la comunidad tenía como una
asociación con los pastizales antes la
gente tenía vacas o borregos y subían
aquí al bosque para que se alimentarán
ni siquiera tenían que comprar algún
alimento
el pastizal también lo utilizaban para
fabricar escopetas cepillos o incluso
hasta escobas
también los utilizaban para para cocinar
los tamales en la olla le ponía en el
fondo parte del pastizal y esto es para
que no se quemará en los temas cuales lo
extienden para que cuando se bañen no se
lastiman y tenían muchos más usos los
pastizales y la gente si los reconocía
con el tiempo y la cercanía con la
ciudad de mexico la gente dejó de
trabajar en el campo y dejó de tener
animales porque tenía que ir a trabajar
a alguna fábrica en la ciudad y se fue
perdiendo esta relación
los pastizales son de gran importancia
porque hacen captura de carbono
hacen infiltración de agua
dulce y también
evitan la erosión
aquí en mi falta los son muy importantes
porque a pesar de esos servicios que nos
brindan también existen dos especies en
peligro extinción que es el gorrión
serrano y el conejo sacapuc y
el gorrión serrano es una de las
especies que depende al cien por ciento
de los pastizales anida en los macollos
de los pastos y no se acercan la zona
arbolada el gorrión serrano hace vuelos
cortos y se alimenta de las espigas de
los pastos
normalmente
para huir de sus depredadores se baja al
suelo y corre debajo de los pastizales
también tenemos al conejo saca tu che el
conejo saca tu che también se alimenta
de los pastos y en ocasiones hace nidos
en el centro del maco yo para que ahí
sus gazapos o sus crías puedan crecer
también utiliza al pasto para que se
camuflaje de los depredadores o para
poder escapar de ellos
entre algunas este madrigueras de
algunas cosas o de otros mamíferos que
se encuentran en los pastizales
a partir de esto se crea un grupo de
monitoreo biológico
preocupados por conservar a estas dos
especies que se encuentran en peligro de
extinción por lo que hace siete años
preocupados por ver cómo podíamos
conservar a estas dos especies
empezamos a hacernos preguntas y ver
cómo podríamos conservarlos y creemos
que lo primero era conocerlas saber
dónde viven donde anidan qué comen
quiénes son sus depredadores
y después de conocer todo esto saber
porque son especies que están en peligro
de extinción
cuando nos empezamos a meter y conocer
sobre estas especies nos dimos cuenta
que lo que se está perdiendo en su
hábitat son los pastizales naturales
observamos que cada año se quema el 90%
de los pastizales por incendios
forestales
que en los últimos 10 años se está
perdiendo el hábitat debido al cambio de
uso de suelo
principalmente por papas y avena
y lo más grave es que al sembrar papa le
están metiendo demasiados agroquímicos y
los pastizales son los que más se
infiltran entonces posiblemente también
en algunos años se van a afectar a la
población más cercana
incluso a la ciudad de mexico
preocupados por esto el grupo empezó a
buscar algunas alternativas de que estar
haciendo para conservar estas especies
identificamos que los incendios les
habían afectado entonces creamos una
estrategia para hacer manejo de los
pastizales
sabiendo que hay algunas estrategias
preventivas como son las quemas
controladas las quisimos modificar
inventamos una una nueva línea que le
llamamos quemasen manchones tipo dálmata
post
y esta para disminuir el riesgo de que
cuando le prendan los pastizales se
quemarán al cien por ciento o al 90%
ahora con los manchones tipo dálmata
podríamos crear zonas de resguardo de
las especies y romper la continuidad del
fuego cuando cuando aquí se prendieron
también cuando
observamos que se estaba perdiendo los
pastizales debido al cambio de uso de
suelo
inventamos una estrategia que nosotros
le llamamos rep astíz acción esta
repartición consiste en
en lugar de plantar árboles este
restaurar con los mismos pastos nosotros
en los caminos podemos encontrar pastos
que a veces afectan la entrada y esos
pastos no sólo lo reubica vamos en zonas
que habían sido perturbadas y hacíamos
algunos esquejes para que se rompiera
para poder hacer corredores de
conectividad
hace cinco años hicimos nuestra primera
parcela demostrativa
y lo que logramos es que después de
cinco años el gorrión serrano pudo
anidar en en estos pastos que nosotros
plantamos y pudimos lograr que hubiera
anidación exitosa y es increíble porque
fue con una especie que está en peligro
de extinción
a pesar de todo lo que hemos observado
aquí en los pastizales
estamos preocupados estén tristes
y actualmente no sabemos qué hacer por
qué
parece que nadie le toma importancia
pues no
actualmente los pastizales
pues sirven para roturar se o sirven
para meter campañas de reforestaciones
masivas y no le dan el valor a este
ecosistema
desde hace más de 20 años le han querido
meter árboles a los pastizales y ya le
está ganando terreno pues no ya se están
creando
algunas zonas de arbolada con con
densidades muy altas
actualmente también tenemos un problema
porque como van creciendo los árboles y
van cerrando sus copas van eliminando la
vegetación que se encuentra debajo
nosotros a este a este efecto le
llamamos desiertos verdes porque si tú
observas en la parte de arriba
puedes encontrar un bosque verde o
bonito pero si tú lo observas debajo se
está perdiendo la vegetación ya se están
eliminando los pastos y todos los
arbustos
en estas zonas donde nosotros les
decimos desiertos verdes
también buscamos hacer alguna
alternativa para restaurar y hay una que
le llamamos silvicultura preventiva y la
cual consiste en eliminar algunos
árboles muertos en pie torcido
bifurcados y algunos por competencia
y esto lo queremos hacer como una
parcela demostrativa porque ya es un
problema en milpa alta ya tenemos
incendios de copa debido a que están muy
juntos
y de que ya no existe nada de vegetación
debajo y bueno esta estrategia ha sido
complicada porque en la ciudad de méxico
está vedado y no permite que se haga un
tipo de manejo entonces queremos
demostrar que el bosque que más que
restarles reforestando necesitamos y
empezar le a dar un manejo diferente
porque después de 20 años
seguimos teniendo los mismos problemas
tenemos que tomar las cosas en serio por
eso nosotros hemos buscado una
asociación con las universidades con las
dependencias y tenemos que trabajar de
forma conjunta pues ya cada ecosistema
le tenemos que dar su valor y su
importancia cada trabajo que hagamos en
el bosque pues tiene que ser enfocado
realmente a cómo está el ecosistema y
cómo lo podemos ir mejorando
porque ahorita
actualmente ya no se está ganando ya se
escucha muy cerca lo del cambio
climático tan solo en la comunidad
siempre había sido fría y ahorita pues
ya casi hay temporadas donde ya no
soporta el calor
antes el agua era vasta y actualmente ya
no las están cambiando esto nos quiere
decir que el cambio climático ya lo
tenemos aquí y que el trabajo que
estamos haciendo lo tenemos que hacer no
solo con ideas sino ya tenemos que hacer
investigaciones reales y trabajos
funcionales
a nosotros nos tocó conservar y entender
a los pastizales tú si estás en un
bosque en una selva en un desierto te
recomendamos que lo entiendas que lo
analicen y vean qué es lo que necesitan
no hagan acciones superficiales como las
reforestaciones no traten de cumplir
sólo metas cumplan objetivos reales y
que sean funcionales
por eso los invitamos a que cuiden su
ecosistema y hagan acciones que
realmente les funcionen a cada uno de
ellos
[Música]
[Aplausos]